The rate of scientific discovery is getting
faster and faster, with major discoveries
happening every year, rather than every century.
Mars landings, gravitational waves, cancer
treatments, vegan chili con carne, we really
do seem to be able to achieve the unthinkable.
But that’s not to say we do it all on our
own.
Since the dawn of civilization, animals have
been more than just our faithful companions
and our delicious lunch; they have been a
vital part of our understanding of how the
world works and often an inspiration for how
to make it a better place.
So go give Barkin’ Scorsese an extra cookie,
let Meowly Cyrus up on the bed, and together
you can learn about 7 animals who have helped
advance science.
Dogs need space, lots of it.
Although the Soviets may have taken this a
bit far with the legendary dog Laika, when
they fired her out the atmosphere and made
her the first animal to orbit the earth.
Mankind has had a long history of firing animals
into the sky, since 1738 when the Montgolfier
brothers sent a sheep, a duck and a rooster
up in a hot air balloon.
The sheep was named Montauciel, which means
climb-to-the-sky.
They believed a sheep to have roughly similar
physiology to a human and the duck and rooster
were control animals, this was science after
all.
But also because they thought it was funny
to see how a sheep, a duck and rooster get
on together in a spaceship.
This set the standard and by the 1940s, the
skies were filled with balloons and rockets
being tested by frogs, fruit flies, fish and
monkeys, among many others.
It was like a Disney movie directed by Michael
Bay.
Laika was sent into orbit on November 3, 1957,
to test how both the g-force of the launch
and micro-gravity would affect a living organism.
Poor Laika just believed that someone had
thrown a stick really, really far.
The brave beast died within hours from overheating
but there was never any intention of bringing
her home, which many of the scientists say
they regretted later on.
If you were ever mugged by a sheep and had
to pick one out of a police line-up, you’d
probably struggle.
This may be why the Roslin Institute in the
University of Edinburgh, decided to use sheep
as clone subjects; if it didn’t work, they
could have just grabbed any other sheep and
said “look, see, they’re just like twins.”
But work it did and Dolly the Sheep was born
on 5 July 1996.
She was named Dolly since the original cell
was taken from a mammary gland, which made
the team think of Dolly Parton, the famously
glandular singer.
Like an extreme episode of the Jeremy Kyle
show, Dolly had 3 different mothers; one gave
the egg, one gave the DNA and the final one
did the whole pregnancy thing.
Actually I think I watched that episode last
week.
Although not the first cloned animal, Dolly
was the first clone of an adult, proving that
you could revert an organism back to the embryonic
state.
The process is called somatic cell nuclear
transfer, where you take out the nucleus of
a developing egg cell and put in the nucleus
of a developed adult cell; like putting your
grandad in a pair of Converse and skinny jeans
and seeing if he fits in at Skrillex concert.
More Red Bull grandpops?
Thanks to Dolly, we may be able to preserve
endangered species and even revive extinct
ones by the process she helped to pioneer.
Do you find your goldfish suspicious, always
staring at you with those goggly eyes and
gormless expression?
Well, it may be a soviet spy.
We’ve used many different beasts for spying
over the centuries; pigeons carrying messages,
dogs that can sniff out weapons and cats that
are really good at hacking; well I assume
that’s why they always sit on your keyboard
looking suspicious.
Recently, Hamas captured an aquatic spy near
the coast of the Gaza Strip, it was a dolphin.
Both Israeli and Palestinian media said that
Double O Dolphin was equipped with recording
devices and even an arrow-firing weapon.
It’s thought that he was there to take video
of the frogmen training facility, presumably
so they could plan an attack using a ninja
octopus and a really angry seahorse.
Dolphin secret agents are not a new thing
though; we’ve been using them since the
1960s for a variety of porpoises (purposes).
Both the US and the Soviets had dolphin teams
to spot underwater mines and they still do
since their echo location is still far superior
to any tech we’ve been able to create so
far.
As far as killing goes, there have been no
reported incidents but ex-Navy Seal, Brandon
Webb, talked in his memoir about training
dolphins to head-butt enemy targets with a
compressed needle, which could inject lethal
bubbles of CO2 into their blood.
Beware the killer spy dolphins.
The Israelis have been accused of having a
whole zoo of animal agents, from masterminding
the shark attack in Sharm el Sheikh to a surveillance
vulture captured in Saudi Arabia.
I’m looking forward to Bacon Bourne, the
swine sleeper agent.
Speaking of porky animals, Ham the Chimp was
another great in the story of space exploration.
Ham was born in what was then The French Cameroons
but was shipped to the US at a young age to
join the School for Space Chimps at the Holloman
Air Force Base in Alamagordo, New Mexico.
This was all part of Project Mercury, the
NASA mission to put a human into space.
On the last day of January 1961, Ham was strapped
into a nappy and then into a rocket where
he spent 16 minutes being successfully launched
up to zero gravity and then coming back down
in his capsule.
He helped NASA gain valuable data about the
life support systems they would use soon after
for Alan Shepard, the first American and second
human to enter space.
But how did Ham feel about all this?
Famous primate expert Jane Goodall was highly
critical of the mission and on reviewing the
footage said that she had never seen a chimp
look more terrified.
Sergio Canavero is a maverick surgeon who
has been working his way up the animal chain
with the dubious aim of performing a full
human head transplant.
Dr. Vladimir Demikhov led a lot of our advancement
in the field of transplanting, performing
a lot of different operations in the 40s and
50s and pioneering the use of immuno-suppressants
so that the body would accept the new body
part.
And in 1959 he even transplanted a dog’s
head onto a new body.
Neurosurgeon, Robert J. White, performed a
successful monkey head transplant in 1970
with the animal surviving long enough to see,
smell and hear the world around it.
It then decided it didn’t think much of
the world around it and proceeded to bite
people.
So it’s undoubtedly possible for humans
but the ethical questions it raises are pretty
big; how do you define a person?
Am I only me above the nipples?
Above the neck?
And what if the body I’m transplanted onto
has a One Direction tattoo; death would probably
be a better option.
Our final scientific assistant is a wee bionic
beast who, like his namesake Oscar Pistorius,
bounces around on blades.
Oscar lost both his back legs in a nasty accident
with a combine harvester, down on the channel
island of Jersey.
His owners rejected advice to have him put
down and soon they were communicating with
neuro-orthopaedic surgeon Noel Fitzpatrick
in the UK and organizing for Oscar to have
specially engineered, honeycomb-shaped implants
that would be drilled directly into his remaining
ankle bones.
This technique was designed to mimic how deer
antlers grow and allow skin to grow over the
point where the implant joins the body and
so prevent infection.
The whole process probably cost about £50,000
but most of that was covered by the pioneering
doctors, rather than the owners and the knowledge
they gained has now been used to help humans,
such as a woman injured in the July 2005 London
bombings.
So rather than just putting your hamster on
a wheel or getting your puppy to play fetch,
maybe try something a little more challenging
as your pet may have the key to the cure for
cancer or they could just teach you a really
useful shortcut on Microsoft excel.